i thought it would be fun to
make some christmas arts and crafts
while i was procrastinating on
making a video about how i finally
finished my phd
but uh it kind of ended up being
a lot more mathematical than i expected
and
a bit of a nightmare to be honest uh
what is that
it's my calculator um and then the thing
is it didn't even look nice in the end
but it was kind of fun in its own way
and so i decided to put this video
up anyway
the thing with this video was that i
wanted to start it without any plans
about how i was going to do it in mind
because i thought that doing it that way
would be more fun
and so you're gonna see me make loads of
mistakes
and have to start again a few times
okay so my idea um
is to make this into a
a cone and then i'm going to
add leaves that come out from the cone
so let's make the cone first
what i want to do is make these leaves
coming off the tree like this
um around the tree but i need to decide
how to space them
so what i'm going to do i reckon is have
a spiral
that goes around the tree and then
place the leaves along that spiral
my first guess is that we could try and
find out what the geodesics
of this cone are um so a geodesic
is a path on a curved surface that is
locally flat say you wanted to get
between two points
on your cone so here's point a
and here's point b
now you could go in a fairly direct
manner
um but what is the short shortest route
what is the most direct route
is it this straight line is it a
slightly
curved downwards line is a slightly
curved upwards line
i don't know but how can you find out
well
there's a theorem in geometry that the
shortest path
between two points is one that is
locally flat in other words is a
geodesic
now how can we find this
locally flat path and what does that
even mean
well firstly let's uh imagine that you
are going to go on a path that is
definitely not the shortest one so let's
say something like this
how can we tell that that's not locally
flat well
if it was locally flat then this piece
of tape
should sit flat on it but
instead what we're going to see is we
can't get the tape to sit flat
it's going to have to distort like this
to get between those two points so that
is definitely not a geodesic
now what happens if we do put a locally
flat
piece of tape between those two so in
other words
a piece of tape where the tape doesn't
crinkle in either direction
so i'm going to hold it taut just
it's not quite the right angle
i'm going to hold it taut
and here that is the shortest path
between those two things
and you can tell because this tape is
sitting flat on it
so i'm going to use this tape as a guide
to find this geodesic you can see here
that i haven't quite done this right
because
the tape is sort of sticking up here and
if you try and push it down it doesn't
quite sit flat
um now that is going to happen even if i
was on the geodesic
um this will only really work with like
infinitely small tape
you know in theory mathematically but uh
it should be close enough and so i think
that i've actually got this
slightly wrong it should be more like
yeah that's it that's
that there is more like a geodesic so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
get some tape and i'm going to put it
around
this cone in a geodesic up to this point
and i'm going to see whether it actually
does uh look nice or not
so do it like that all right
now to get the geodesic i have to pull
this tape
taut and then just see where it wants to
land
oof got a bad feeling about this this is
a very tight spiral it's almost
overlapping when it comes around
yeah okay so you can see here
you can see here that if i let it go
where it wants to go
um it actually oh interesting it
actually comes back down
oh maybe the geodesic doesn't even go
up this cone at all hmm
okay let me test this i ashamed it would
i'm kind of surprised
why did i assume that it would go up
i'm not sure okay let's see let's see
this is fun it's like doing maths but
through experiments
like hands-on experiments completely
different from
how i learned differential geometry in
university
okay so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
put it on a pretty steep angle
and then see what happens
okay oop that's not likely flat there
oh that doesn't feel flat yeah okay
let's see okay that's pretty flat
yeah it's looking good okay
oh looks like it's spiraling up okay
oh no no no no
it's uh yeah it's coming back down
interesting oh wait uh let me
let me see i've stuffed this up a little
bit in fact it goes
back down even steeper wow
that's weird
wow this is
weird the line doesn't go up the cone
at all in fact it goes up
as you can see here and then changes its
mind
kind of just goes in a circle for a bit
and then
starts coming back down to end up here
that's really interesting so i was wrong
there is no geodesic that spirals up the
cone
it seems let me verify that
okay so i've been thinking a bunch i
even got my whiteboard out and did a few
little sketches
and here's what i'm thinking let's say
that the spiral starts down here
i want it to come round
and meet back at this line at some point
up up this length so why don't i make
that point that it comes back and meets
this point
like some fraction of the total length i
reckon a quarter
so i reckon it comes around once ends up
a quarter up the height
then let's pretend as if the rest of the
cone doesn't exist
now and we want to do the same procedure
we want to pretend that this is our new
total length
and we want the next round of the spiral
to
come up one quarter of this length
not the previous length so
then let's say that's about
here and then we do the process again
it's like this is the new cones length
we want the
new point to be one quarter of the way
along
that length so it's about here
etc quarters are easy because you can
find them pretty easily by just folding
so let's do that
fold in half once
twice
then you tear off that little bit and
now you've got to find
one quarter of this new length
etc
if you could do this accurately there
would be an infinite number
of lines before you reach the actual top
we're going to stop before that happens
because i don't have the time you might
be wondering
why i chose this pattern i wanted this
tree to have
a property called self-similarity what
that means is
if you look at a smaller part of this
tree so
for example instead of looking at this
full tree if you
cut it off at this point and you just
looked at the smaller one
you would want that to look exactly
proportional
to the full tree and the reason you can
see that is because
this full tree has its first
spiral like wrap around coming back at
this point which is one quarter
up its full length whereas this smaller
version of the tree
um has its first spiral coming up at
this point
which is also one quarter up the length
of the tree
right and so there both of them will
look exactly the same
just one is smaller than the other think
that
this will make it look a little bit more
realistic and i also think it will look
really really pretty but let's find out
um what i wanted to do was have
these branches coming out of
uh the tree arranged in around the tree
like this
but up the spiral such that the one that
ends up approximately here so that is
one step up the spiral
i want that to be one quart what three
quarters rather
of the size of the one below but
the problem with this is that
um well because i have a cone here
uh the length thing isn't gonna quite
work out actually this one's gonna be a
lot longer than three quarters
of this one because this one is uh
starting from a much further in point
so so i think
even though it was a lot of effort
to make this thing i think i'm gonna
have to start again
with something more like a straw
trees have this problem where they want
to put out
branches or leaves but they want to make
sure
that the next leaves
are not overlapping too much
because that would mean that there would
be
that there would have to be a lot of
leaves to catch the same amount of
sunlight
right and so you want to avoid this
problem so
the question is if you put your first
leaf down here what angle should the
next leaf be
away from this leaf for example should
it be like this
apparently this is a question that has
been studied before
and i don't know what the analysis is
but apparently the answer to this
question is
that this angle should be something
called the golden
angle and yes it is very related to the
golden ratio
but i'm not going to explain what the
golden ratio is and i'm definitely not
going to explain
why this is the right answer instead
what we're going to do
right now is we're going to see if
visually this does seem about right the
golden angle is an irrational number
but it's approximately 138
degrees which is very very close
to 3 8
of a full circle which is convenient for
us
so we're going to just assume that it is
3 8 of
a full circle and then go from there
the area is very very small
so if our first leaf goes here
our second leaf should go 3
8 of the circle around which is so this
is
a half of the circle and that's a
quarter so that's three eighths
so it's here that's where the next leaf
would be
next one after that is
here so you can see something
really nice about this is that while
there is little bits of overlap
so far there hasn't been any direct
overlap and yet this space has been
filled very efficiently
now this last petal
or rather last leaf is going to go here
so that is some direct overlap
how many times around did we go before
we got
to this overlapping leaf well it's three
times
and the reason we know that is because
each time we go
around we go three-eighths of the circle
so by the time we've gone eight of these
we've gone around three times but
something that i've clearly gotten wrong
here is
that these petals don't get smaller in
the right proportions you can see how
this one is
huge compared to well everything else
and that's not quite right that's
definitely not how trees look
it is certainly the case that the leaves
get smaller
as they go up the tree but
not in this proportion all right so
let's figure out those proportions
so here's our tree trunk let's say that
it has
length l capital l if there was a leaf
right at the bottom or a branch
let's say with length little l
and then there was one here what length
should this one be
well so the point that we've gone up to
here is
three quarters of l remember we marked
out these lengths
this way because what we wanted was that
if we chopped the tree here
what we would get is a miniature version
of the full tree
it would just be shrunk down so
everything would be shrunk down by three
quarters
the length would be three quarters of
the original and
also we want the leaves the length of
those leaves themselves to also be three
quarters of the original
so this leaf that was at the bottom of
the the full tree should become a
leaf here that's three quarters of that
length
so here it should be three quarters
the problem for us though is that if we
have a leaf here
of length l the next leaf up the tree
is not here but in fact it's a golden
ratio
rotated along so it's like here
now what length should this new leaf be
well let's think about it like this
um if it had been here and it had
rotated
the whole way around then it would be
three quarters
but it's only now rotated three
eighths of the way we need to figure out
what this function is
and then figure out what its value is 3
8 of the way between these two points
it so happens that this is actually a
nice function and a very important one
it's called the exponential although in
this case it's
uh exponential decrease on this axis
we're going to have the number of
rotations and on
that axis we're going to have
length
of leaf the first leaf
has gone zero rotations around the tree
and its length
is l we know that
if a leaf were to go around one full
rotation
its length has to become three quarters
of
l about here after
two rotations
it has to be three quarters of that
this function is exponential decrease
our next leaf is 3 8 of a rotation
so we need to figure out what is this
length
there's a nice way to do it all we need
to do is figure out
what is the function for for this thing
if we call the number of rotations x
then the length
of a leaf that has gone around
x rotations is 3 over 4
to the power of x times
l all we have to do is put in
3 8.
that's 3 to the power of 4
to the power of 3 8 times l
which equals approximately oh
very very close to 90 percent
of l which means that each
successive leaf has to be 90
of the previous one which is just awful
that is going to be a nightmare to
measuring out
okay i think that the best way to do it
is to
measure them all out in advance so let's
do that
um okay but one thing i need to do is
approximate how many i'll need in total
so
there are 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 maybe 13
rotations that i want to do let's say
let's say 12
because that's nice 12 is 4 lots of
3 and in 3 rotations
we get 8 petals so that means that
we'll have um around eight times three
petals or leaves or whatever it is
in total oh my god i'm tired
uh what is that it's my calculator
three eight times three
24 apparently okay i'm going to make 24
leaves
each one having 90 of the length of
the previous one okay so i went ahead
and
measured out the lengths um up until
17 then they just kind of get really
small so i don't think it matters too
much
but now i have to make those branches
or leaves so what i've decided to do
is i've got this piece of paper and
folded in half
because the longest of
these is about half
of the paper then
what i'm going to do hopefully
successfully
is make a bunch of triangles
out of this paper that are all isosceles
um and then i will trim them down to
these lengths
let's say this is my first leaf and i
want the second one to be
90 of the length of that original one
um i could make it 90 of the length by
cutting it here
but i also want it to be 90 of the width
in other words i just want it to be
this this actual triangle but
all of the dimensions scaled down 90
then actually just cutting it will do
that
and that's because you can see that this
if i was to cut it
say here the angles are still the same
this angle and this angle are the same
and these two angles
are still the same and so it is still a
congruent triangle
and therefore these two will be the same
as each other just scaled down in both
dimensions
okay there you have it the exponential
decay function
as a bunch of leaves oh that is
badly off
i decided that i'm going to stick the
rest on with
the hot glue gun because this is looking
really trash right now and i wanna see
if
it's gonna keep looking like that um
when
i stick everything on and it's not
flopping around
so yeah let me do that all right
what i need to decide is what to do
about this top
because i could keep adding leaves and
that would be fine except it's going to
be
a lot more leaves to fill this
you can see that these lines are getting
very very close to it
together and it's kind of tedious to
make these like very little leaves
but then what happens to that that top
section
what i was hoping was that the nearer to
the top
leaves would be big enough to kind of
curl over the top
so that you wouldn't you wouldn't need
to worry about the
the like infinite number of leaves that
should be there
but what i didn't take into account is
that of course the length of these
leaves
is getting smaller proportionally and so
that isn't going to happen all right so
this is the final product and
as you can see uh what i did for the top
was i just added a cone
there instead with the right height um i
think this is actually kind of a fair
way to finish this off
because it does have the right sort of
proportion for this to actually work the
whole thing should be a cone
and so i should you know try and make
sure that this cone is has the right
sort of angle as the rest but i
really can't be bothered so whatever
anyway
you can see that this tree kinda looks
alright from above
but from the side you can see just how
sparse it is so it doesn't look great
and the thing that really went wrong
there
is a constant that i picked right near
the start
there's only one variable that i chose
for this tree
and it was how quickly um the leaves
would spiral around
so if you remember i chose it so that
the
leaves would go around once
by the time they got up a quarter of the
tree so then if i were to cut off the
tree
there then the next round of leaves
would go up once
by the time they get up to the quarter
of the new tree
and so that was the variable that i
chose and clearly it was way too big
like there needs to be far far more
leaves
before the tree gets up one quarter at
the moment there's only three
so i really hadn't thought about that
and if you are going to do a similar
project to this
i recommend you pick a a much smaller
number than that
which is a little bit of a pain because
it means that you're going to be putting
on a lot of leaves
but uh i guess that's the price to pay
if you want it to look pretty
if you don't care about it look from
looking pretty you can just do what i
did
voila all right
i think i'm gonna call it a day it's
actually been three days that i've been
working on this
on this tree and uh i'm tired
and i don't want to do any arts and
crafts for a while
thanks for watching